And the way we do that is the process
is called de-identification.
De-identification essentially
says drop or
remove all the values that
identify a particular user.
Now, de-identification
alone is not sufficient.
Sometimes we have to do what
is called anonymization.
So, think about the example where
there was only one student with junior
standing.
Although we dropped the student ID
that directly identified that student.
But the standing field or
attribute will tell us,
even without the ID,
who that particular tuple is about.
So one way to do that is you can
do some sort of anonymization.
And one way to do anonymization
is what's called generalization.
So you replace an exact value
by a set of values or a range.
So, we may combine
junior-senior standing and
we can just say upperclassmen or
something like that.
And if you only have juniors and
seniors, then that would then avoid that
problem we had where the junior standing
identified a particular student.
So, even when you do
the de-identification and
anonymization it has
to be done with care.
Depending on your data set that you
have, or what's stored in the database,
this may not be sufficient.
Think of an example where we're looking
at people, with certain diseases,
who live in various zip codes.
So, well someone may be able to make
some sort of an inference based on a zip
code and publicly available information,
addresses, and things like that.
So, we may want to drop the last
digit of the zip code, or
the last two digits of the zip code.
So that's one way to generalize it.
Okay?
So, Georgia Tech is 30332.
If we replace the last two by zero zero,
then perhaps the three digits we
have match with a much larger area.
But what if,
even after you do that generalization,
the disease that we have is the same
across all those different zip
codes where the first
three digits are the same?
The disease values are not
diverse enough, let's say,
if they're exactly the same.
Everybody has some sort of infectious
disease or something like that,
which CDC maybe looking at on how
those infections are spreading out and
stuff like that.
Generalization won't do anything
on that case, isn't it?
Because it's the same value C same
disease D for example that we didn't
want someone to see that this particular
zip code had incidence of that disease.
That's why we do the realization saying
well it could be any of the four or
eight or whatever number of zip codes
when you replace the last two digits by
zero zero.
But if the values,
the disease values are not diverse then
just generalizing or anonymizing
the zip code value doesn't go very far.
So in a generally,
either this transformation involves
de-identification, generalization,
anonymization.
There are things called k-anonymities so
they're at least multiple tuples and
you focus on certain subset of
the values that could be used as a quasi
identifier are the same in the database
And then we have to see that
across the same set of quasi-identifiers
that we have, they're multiple values,
so we can't say that given
an identifier that we have here, for
sure we know that this must
be the sensitive value.